can ask you about love
oh sure uh i'm feeling it
you know like we're an hour or two here
lex yeah you feel you're good we could
become besties
we're good we got a bromance going here
alexa i feel it too
if it's eric weinstein level but i feel
like it's close
yeah i'm feeling the love but you we
talked about the
there's music to my ears your whole rant
on the
the olympic nature of a startup
is there a role like what role does love
family friendship play in that
brutal pursuit of excellence that is
building a startup building a company or
building any creating anything new in
this world
such a great question um and and totally
unprepared for it
uh because i know nobody would ever ask
me about that so i think it's why you've
you've got quite a following uh on your
podcast is that you're able to ask these
questions and
um i could tell one story because uh you
know i don't talk about
i try not to talk about relationship
with elon that often because
you know he's so famous now yeah i mean
when we met i used to go out to parties
with him
and people like oh my god you're jason
calcasa yeah and like who's your friend
i'm like where's my friend elon he's
and they'd be like what he's doing
rocket ships but he's told this story
publicly
so i can tell it it would never talk
about anything that he hasn't already
talked about publicly especially since
he saw a high profile but it was a
pretty funny moment
um he there there was a moment in time
when tesla almost went out of business
and you've probably heard the story uh
many times but it was during the
financial crisis and
uh they were running out of money and
they said uh
uh you know let's go get a stake and
we're in la and we drove to boa and i
had my orange tesla roadster and he had
his
p1 or p2 like the red one that i think
is in space now
um and we drove to the valet and we had
a stake together and we're sitting there
and i said you know i read the story and
gawker or whatever you know and
new york times here you only got like
five weeks of money left in tesla
because it's not true i was like oh
thank god he goes we have two weeks
i was like oh god i was like well what's
going on with the rocket ship company
yeah you know like you know i know you
did the one
last month and don't you have one coming
up he's like yeah we got the third one
coming up i was like well
how's that going as well we'd blow that
one up there's no more spacex
i was like so two weeks of money left in
tesla and spacex you blew up the first
two rockets you blow up the third spacex
is over he's like yeah
i was like i can load you a couple
million dollars i don't have like a ton
um he's like it's okay our friend beep
has loaned me some money
and elon's been super public about this
i would never tell the story unless he
hadn't been but he
was talking he never said who it was but
somebody had loaned him money to keep
him afloat
he was he was functionally bankrupt i
mean he had the equity in the companies
but the equity was quickly becoming
worth zero and the financial crisis and
he's
figuring out if he's gonna go on
vacation for christmas or not and he's
on the phone trying to
you know um you know save the save both
companies
and i said certainly there must be some
good news and he takes that as
blackberry
to date this conversation there are no
iphones he does blackberry and he starts
swiping
and he says don't tell anybody this is
what i'm building
and he shows me the model s
and nobody knew that was working on the
model s we knew he's
doing the mo the roadster and was trying
to save the company
and i looked at it and i was like that's
gorgeous um
it was the clay models so it's a
full-size clay model so there's human
beings standing around a clay version of
this tiny little blackberry picture i'm
scrolling through on the
remember that little uh pad or the ball
on the background scrolling through
i'm like this is [ __ ] great and i
just said to him it's like
uh what's the range going to be as well
i think we get 250 miles like
250 miles yeah i think it'd be the
safest car ever i said what is it going
to cost
he says i think this could cost
eventually 50 60 000
i said elon if you make that car you'll
change the goddamn world
you have to this company must survive
because
the roadsters for like 2 000 people in
the united states
this car is for every person in the
united states
every single person in the united states
needs will want this car if it's 50
000 and maybe some of the people who you
have 20 or 30 000 won't be able to
afford it but they'll all want it
it's gorgeous and he said you really
think so i said yeah
so i got home and i talked to my wife
jade and i said you have the checkbook
she does all the finances and stuff like
that pays over the bills and whatever
and i said um yeah don't tell anybody
elon's making this great car
and i wrote two checks for fifty
thousand dollars and i just took a piece
of paper and i wrote
e comma uh love
love the new car i'll take two
and i signed it i kissed the two fifty
thousand shacks put them in the envelope
and i fedexed it to them for monday
delivery and i said to jade
that hundred thousand dollars is going
to be gone
in 48 hours because we'll pay for one or
two days of payroll on tesla
so we just added like instead of two
weeks of roadways got 12 days
yeah and uh the checks don't cash but
then i read a story that he's
closed the money saved the company in
like the next week or two
and a couple of months later uh the
checks
get cashed and i'm like okay three years
later i get an email
your reservation number it's from tesla
your reservation number is zero zero
zero
zero zero zero zero one and then
five seconds later your reservation
number is zero zero zero zero seventy
three
and i forward the number one to elon i
said uh you know
i can't take number one a signature
number one i can't take that
that's yours yeah it's like well i got
five of them and besides you're the
first person to ordered it
and i was the first person who had seen
you didn't give me the deterio and then
i
know it was a very beautiful moment it
was an incredible moment for both of us
and we talk about it sometimes
uh you know those moments in time and
when you to your point about love
like the darkest moment one of the
darkest moments in his life probably
that i think it was i could tell you it
was the darkest period of his life for
sure
and he's been very public about how dark
that was and i think you know
this is why i have great sympathy for
the entrepreneurs of the world like the
suffering and the pain
and when he talks about the suffering
and the pain that all of these founders
have felt and then we we're throwing
rocks at them we're criticizing them as
they try to change the world and save
humanity
and in tesla's case i mean they weren't
you know
they weren't like delivering pizza i
mean they were trying to get us off of
fossil fuels like this was a big
heady mission to literally save the
environment the planet humanity
and the way they shorted that stock and
they attacked him
it was always perplexing to me why
any human being who is standing on god's
green earth
would want to throw rocks at the guy who
is trying to stem
the dam of global warming that is about
to engulf
all of us how dare they throw rocks at
that guy
yeah there's so many people you throw
rocks at there's somebody who's making
the jewel
vaporizer throw rocks at that scumbag no
offense
but like whoever's making the jewel
things and you know selling pina colada
flavor to 12 year olds
like throw rocks at them somebody's
doing something you know abhorrent but
not e
i mean and uh yeah anyway that that car
is you know up the road here sitting
under a cover
yeah with 20 000 miles on it in my
garage
and then the roadster number 16 is in
the garage next to it and every day i
walk by the two of them
and i get a warm feeling in my heart
because i know he did it yeah
against all odds against all odds he
pulled it off uh and it was
that moment that month in that 2000 it
was jan it was probably december january
december of 2008 i think it was just 12
years ago when you think about 13 years
ago
it was dark i mean it was dark and they
they almost had the same thing happen
uh you know in the model 3 production in
june of two years three years ago
and i remember him just trying to get
the model 3 out the door and the company
almost crashed then
you